first of all this is not my attempt to
cancel dave chappelle to get him in
trouble to get him fired anything like
that this video is just meant to provide
another perspective to these jokes that
dave is telling to hopefully kind of
balance out the negative impacts that
they can have second disclaimer i have
watched the entirety of the closer
specials good for you at the very least
if you're going to critique it you
should watch in the entirety and a lot
of people didn't before they lost their
mind so good for you that being said i
have not however watched any other
videos or read any articles about it
because i wanted to form my own opinions
wanted to be as unbiased as possible the
last disclaimer before we get started is
i think there is a conversation that can
be had about comedy as a form of
quote-unquote moral immunity or whatever
you want to call it basically the idea
that you can be as offensive or damaging
and problematic as you want as long as
you call it comedy it was just a joke
personally as somebody who has studied
media and the effects that it
unavoidably has on all of us i don't
really believe in that i think saying
something deconstructive has just as
much of an impact if not more of an
impact when you say it in comedy or in
this casual setting as it does in other
genres of me if you also are not
familiar with dave chappelle um he is a
straight man not gay not trans none of
the above which i will say i do think it
would make a difference if he was
gay or trans you know anyway i feel like
gay people can make jokes about gay
people trans people can make jokes about
trans people flame monroe makes uh
comedy about lgbtq people and she's
getting flamed no pun intended all the
time
so
people are gonna get offended no matter
what has nothing to do with who whatever
what not okay if you don't align with
what they're saying
people are gonna get mad whenever i hear
this stuff where it's like only black
folks can make jokes about black folks
white folks can make jokes about white
folks and women can only make jokes
about women and men can make tricks
really
women can't make fun of men really
you sure you want to go down that road
because a lot of women's acts are about
to get destroyed listen
we're being honest we make fun of each
other we make fun of ourselves if you
want to do self-deprecation you know
deprecating humor all the time and make
fun of your own community and all this
that's fine do you but then again that's
but this whole thing like you can't make
fun of other groups why why not and also
to what degree do we want to do this
should poor people only be able to make
fun of poor people rich people rich
people no americans americans people can
make fun of rich people because they're
punching up
you see on that layer
if you're on the bottom layer it's
perfectly acceptable for you to punch
everyone upwards if you want to punch
against oppressions acceptable but
oppression cannot punch against the
oppressed yeah i'm not a fan of the
whole punch-up punch down stuff
you know what i mean if you want to go
and make fun of children make fun of
children if children make fun of you
make fun of you
i don't people i i dislike it when
people gatekeep
who can make jokes about who you know
what i'm saying oh you can't you can't
make fun of them they're oppressed why
not why not they're vulnerable people
kids are vulnerable too i love watching
them fall it's hilarious
i like laughing at them when they fall
too yeah
something about watching the little
physics of little people just feet
dangling in the air if somebody is trans
themselves i feel like it's completely
up to them to decide how they want to
talk about their struggles or you know
make art out of their experiences the
same thing goes for race or gender i
think if a black person wants to make
jokes about their struggles with you
know being a black person i think that's
fine i think if a woman wants to make a
joke about being a woman that's fine
however i don't think the opposite is
true i don't think it would be okay for
a white person to joke about a black
person's experience i don't think it'd
be okay for a man to joke about a
woman's experience and i also don't
think it would be okay for a cisgender
person to drug about a trans person's
experience notice
the direction yeah
she didn't say i don't think it's okay
for a black person to make fun of a
white person
or for a woman to make fun of a man she
only said it one way which what yeah i
literally aligns with the one way
yeah
that's a direction and we don't have to
get into the details of the jokes that
he used to make okay they were mean
let's just leave it there usually i find
infatuations of this size to be a little
bit flattering you know it's like cute
you're obsessed with me i get it but
like this is a bit much it's a bit much
you're doing the most aren't you
supposedly one of the greatest comedians
there's a flag you really have to resort
to attacking another minority community
to boost your numbers ain't nobody
trying to talk about y'all that deeply
you guys just won't shut the up and
you guys are in every news article
always
trying to cancel folks of course ain't
nobody talking about native americans or
indigenous folks the same way they're
talking about you no one's talking about
the maui people the same way they're
talking about you the reason why folks
talk about y'all is because you guys put
yourselves out there all the time and
then constantly demanding change from
everybody i could honestly say up until
like
maybe five six years ago the train stuff
wasn't that that common in terms of
stand-up comedy no then the pronoun
stuff we're going to listen to
listen
we laugh comedians is the news if you
look at comedy that did not age well
it's a reflection of not the kami in the
comedian but the era which he lived in
comedy reflects what's going on on a
day-to-day basis every day
it's a reflection that's what we do so
we go outside we go live our best live
we gather information we throw it on the
stage how many comedians has a bit on
kovid because that's all we did for the
past 18 months
because it's current
because we talk about it not because we
just really want to oh no they're really
about that kovac because they're part of
a bigger plan no it's everyday that
we live
so if you talk a lot and you're all in
the news and stuff like that we're going
to talk about it
olympics just passed ufc is happening
there's a whole lot of y'all in the news
of course we're going to be talking
about that same thing as with the george
floyd thing people are going to talk
about that
michael shea just had a special he talks
about the vaccine
because he's part of the propaganda no
because that's all he had to do for the
past 18 months that's it it's a
reflection of the world and where we
live that's it what did what what did
dave chappelle talk about in his special
as well as well he spoke about the baby
the just happened
cause it's current
if you guys are enjoying today's video
make sure you leave a like and a comment
help us out with that algorithm push the
video to everybody that's how you can do
it just smash it okay you're really
struggling that hard right now now i'll
be up front and say that this special
was definitely upsetting to me as a
trans person it hurt my feelings you
know it got me good whether you care if
it hurt my feelings is up to you i
really don't care if you care you know
what i mean like okay you're an
i don't care if you don't care
that was perfect that was perfect that's
not how things work but whatever yeah i
don't care if you care you
piece of i don't
care you got hurt i understand that you
got hurt i understand
but then again that's what it is in a
video
okay you can't be saying
i'm a trans person of course i got hurt
and then minutes before say i'm gonna
give an unbiased opinion
no
okay you
no it's a good point you're biased which
is fine which is fine i get it
also just because you were hurt doesn't
mean the joke was me
or or that it's not because it's not
because the joke was not funny that it's
not a joke you just didn't think it was
funny which is fun listen comedy is
always funny until it's directed at you
and then it's oppressive comedy is just
like a drunk uncle like christmas it's
funny until he touches you there you go
pause regardless of whether or not my
feelings were hurt though there are a
few arcs throughout the special that i
feel are potentially dangerous to the
progress of the trans community the
netflix special starts out and while
there are some funny moments you know
i'll give it to him or some funny
moments there are also a lot of moments
that are problematic and very clearly
indicated where he stood on certain
issues such as coven like he says that
he didn't even get sick from kovid which
is like okay
are you trying to like what do you
what are you trying to say he complains
about the increase of attacks on asian
americans then compares black people
beating up asians to his immune system
fighting off the covet virus that was
funny
[Laughter]
playing into the whole myth of kovit
being this asian disease
which is quite literally the reason that
hate crimes against asian americans has
gone up
that's a funny ass joke that's a funny
ass joke
that's funny
but again if you don't like it you don't
have to like it
you don't have to like it
[Laughter]
i will say that he also does poke fun at
anti-vaxxers and clarifies that he
himself is vaccinated so like
that's good i guess all right we'll give
him we'll give him that we love making
fun of anti-vaxxers so so so you see
it's perfectly acceptable it's perfectly
acceptable to make fun of the groups
that she doesn't like but the group she
does like can't do that how do you think
she's going to react when she finds out
that a lot of the anti-vaxxers are
minorities over-represented probably
doesn't give a but virtue signaling
difference between yeah yeah yeah let's
make fun of that group though i mean i
personally don't care i think everybody
should be able to make fun of everybody
absolutely your lines are all over the
place
the book of his content source the
alphabet people or the btlgs or the or
the the qrf dabble like i don't even
know letters anymore would you what the
is an apple juice but like lgbt
is it really that hard
like just practice it like three times i
swear okay i'm gonna be honest with you
lgbt is a shitty acronym it is like
sometimes you get acronyms and it's like
emma right the word acrony sounds great
lgbtq doesn't sound great lgbtq2ia
sounds stupid and you don't believe me
even the lgbt people say hate the
acronym yeah yeah they constantly
complain why are we adding so many
letters the looks dumb mm-hmm
so i'm lgbtq plus two iaa are there some
people who appreciate having lgbtqia
plus be a thing that exists do they feel
like like it it it helps them be seen or
their friends be seen
anybody here don't know at all okay
sometimes it just gets to be too many
damn letters it's a lot of things
we're technically lgbtqi
a a
p
2 plus
we are not it's
like i said there are a few arcs
throughout the special that i think have
you know transphobic
roots we'll say the first of which
there's three if you're curious the
first of which is the proclamation that
the modern day lgbt movement or the
modern day lgbt community is too
sensitive and too brittle
to be fair though i feel like most
people feel as though most folks have
become too brittle and too frail my
experience is that people feel like the
world is soft yeah black people white
people asians everybody's soft and i'm
really inclusive so i feel like since
you guys are part of the world you're
soft too
soft like charmin
right
so it's okay you guys are soft and
brittle
and it's okay like the rest of the world
you know what's interesting about that
of course the world is going to be soft
and brittle we're not living in hard
times no
there's no reason why you don't know my
struggle shut up okay you're not being
drafted to go to war you're not coming
back with limbs blown off all the time
calm down right back we're at one of the
safest points in history ever
even with covid even with crime it's
nothing like it was in the 90s it's
nothing like it was in the 50s so just
chill so all this to say when people
like people are so soft yay where are
they gonna get the adversity from
you can have ubereats deliver
you food every single day you're
not hunting you don't have to travel to
go anywhere
you're not putting water on your head to
go put you know what i'm saying like
yeah is soft so is the blt
people let's see inclusivity rather that
he just isn't a fan of these newer gays
because like i said they're too
sensitive and they're too brittle and he
then brings up the whole baby situation
to try to show how you know sensitive
and brittle we are and the damage that
we cause to you know good people's
careers is a baby a good person come on
i think she can't recognize sarcasm and
all this other stuff no it's like he's
not necessarily really going for like
the baby's a wonderful human being what
he's trying to say is
you guys would cancel him because he
said a slur but wouldn't cancel him for
killing the person at walmart does that
sound like a defense he didn't say a
slur what the baby no but he talked
about gay folks in a derogatory way yeah
it was not even a slur if you aren't
familiar with the holds a baby situation
i do have a whole video on it you're
welcome but to sum it up really quickly
for you guys basically he said that
people with hiv are dirty he praised
people for not being gay it was a whole
mess and then afterwards he actually
refused to apologize and doubled down on
his homophobia saying that if gay people
want us to accept them for being gay
then they have to accept me for being
homophobic sir
that's not how that works shortly after
a bunch of his shows were canceled
because what music festival is going to
want a performer that bashes a large
portion of their customer base you mean
like eminem
carry on do you mean like most rappers
who say anti-gay stuff
like what do you guys think do you think
your favorite rapper is like gay folks
are you guys not aware that like
homophobia is like very
very very commonplace within the black
community as well as most minority
communities what do you mean
i am not afraid
festivals are hiring people with
homophobies every single day
all the time
i would argue that most
guys go interview your favorite rapper i
can assure you most of them are not down
with gay folks if he's not jaden smith
or tyler the creator
[Music]
i don't know one do you every time i do
something like that i feel like dora
like what do you think is the baby a
dumb
my favorite part of dave calling us too
sensitive though was when he said that
we were being too sensitive and he
misses the the stonewall gaze you know
what the stonewall people did
they started violent riots demanding
respect and demanding equal rights but
calling out how what the baby did is
problematic on twitter is too far
okay dave the aims of the majority of
the lgbt community is not to cancel
everybody that doesn't agree with us or
to get everybody that doesn't agree with
us fired and ruin everybody's lives i
mean i'm sure there are some people out
there that would like that rightfully so
i'm just kidding that's a joke you know
what this reminds me of
this reminds me of that trevor noah
interview where you have somebody who's
not part of the stand-up or comedy scene
or doesn't really get it
trying to dissect every lyric
or every joke whoop whoop is the sound
of the police i just can't imagine
somebody sitting across from like mob
deep and be like
so
when you said
i am not afraid
to shoot
a batsy boy i am not afraid
tell him
stop the war what did you mean by that
so when you said that this is for all
the billers and the hundred dollar
killers
what did you mean
mom people
when you're talking about
burn them
were you using an actual lighter this is
that same thing if you step in a
chichiman bar
what do you mean the af you go dead
yeah that's how it goes
that's because
i got flashbacks yeah these people are
going to ruin everything nas
was it legal when you said you woke up
and you got yourself a gun
woke up this moment
you got yourself a gun
got yourself down yo i'm living in this
time behind enemies
were you mentioning when you said i i
got myself a gun hope you got yours did
you
do you advocate for kyle right nice to
be free oh my god
the comments that dave made honestly
some of them were supportive of things
that would benefit trans people he talks
about the north carolina bathroom bills
and how they were messed up and how they
are ridiculous and you know should never
be a thing but the way that he goes
about it and i know it's comedy you know
it's supposed to just be funny
excuse me
i'm i'm done with this it's not going to
get better it's not going to get better
yeah it's just
it's it's the same rhetoric again and
again we get it okay we get it you you
do we no we get it you don't get secure
degree fine it's okay it's fine
you you don't like the way things were
said and you were hurt i get that you're
biased because i get that okay like you
know what i mean at the end we get it
this is fine it's kind of disappointing
whenever you listen to somebody and you
can just tell that they got literally
all their views from twitter it's the
same stuff you hear verbatim from other
folks
don't punch up punch down all these
other nonsense like bruh it's the same
stuff recycled it's kind of recycled my
mom made it you know what it reminds me
of it's like when we have this whole
conversation about transports
you know trans women be they use the
same arguments she does the same thing
well i mean oh i didn't read any news
articles and it's booboo if you didn't
they informed all your opinions because
nothing you said was an original thought
whatsoever it's the same rehash thing
so for me it was uninteresting and again
it's the same attacks that you
constantly see on comedy what trevor
noah was dealing with six years ago is
exactly remember that bbc article that
was the bbc interview with trevor noah
that was from like five six years you
know i was fighting a year ago do you
feel it's acceptable to make those race
jokes shut up that's ben shapiro that's
not the girl
yeah let us know what you guys think in
the comments below